you know I give the president wide
latitude in his first year there are
things that like the Iraq war that our
membership would like to see and it more
quickly but we understand that this is a
president came into office in the midst
of a rapidly expanding recession two
wars and we have a lot of faith that he
is not just doing the best he can he's
doing the best that can be done very
excited by the past duck the quick
passage of the stimulus bill last year
which includes a lot of money for
restoring schools have been rotting in
this country for decades and create two
and a half million jobs in a time of one
man we you know we need jobs to be
created very excited about the lilly
Ledbetter Fair Pay Act being passed was
the bill that made it possible for women
to really know that that that if they
were have been discriminated against in
the workplace they were going to get the
damn cord and be treated fairly we you
know very excited about the Matthew
Shepard James Byrd bill being passed ian
more importantly about the civil rights
infrastructure being rebuilt and iming
part of our patients to misinterpret I
think the patience of black people in
civil rights leaders in this moment part
of our patient comes because we were
we're more where the most but just how
much damage was done by the Bush
administration to the federal
government's ability to enforce civil
rights and so we've been celebrating you
know people you know of good conscience
being hired into key positions for the
last year and a half now the bar raises
because people are in position or if the
Senate is holding up their nomination
while it's just clear and we got to get
on with it and we're starting to see
good signs secretary Duncan came out the
other day I made a very unequivocal
commitment to ensuring that racial
reseller Gatien racial discrimination
the mistreatment of poor children in
mass in American schools I you know
discrimination gets people who are
learning English for the first time
would be would be treated you know would
be to a top priority
and the actions would be taken forthwith
and and as we speak they're launching a
major investigation in Los Angeles for
instance so we have seen great progress
we have reason to be hopeful and yes
we're patient because we knew that if
you will the starting line for him you
know was probably a hundred years me a
hundred yards back from where should
have been armed and literally between 21
and one in November when he started in
January the direction of the economy
meant that the track was all of a sudden
a pill
you know the the the biggest piece of
the agenda that doesn't seem to be
really even on the radar screen is
serious criminal justice reform a
serious criminal justice reform black
people are fifteen percent of crack
users in this country we use crack like
every other group at about direct
correlation with our percentage of the
population white people are 65 years in
the crack users in this country why
people are five percent were people
locked up for using crack black people
are eighty-five percent of people locked
up for using correct you know that issue
he was very clear when he was
campaigning was you know that that
disparity was was unacceptable and the
disparity that compounds it which is
that the punishments for using crack or
a hundred times stiffer than for using
powder even though it's the same drugs
cocaine um so you know we would like to
see him speak out on criminal justice
issues we would like to see him really
push you know support single support for
Jim Webb's bill to for the country just
to take a look because he knows he knows
his son we've taught constitutional law
who represented the south side of
Chicago who pushed through powerful
law-enforcement accountability bills
when he was in the state Senate in a
state where people were tortured with
impunity you know up until ten years ago
um and and so we would we would like to
hear and see more there we have faith
that it's coming you know his his
appointment of eric holder as our top
long for official was genius and eric
somebody who gets it and eric's and the
president people who are capable of
explaining to the country that this is
about justice for all of us you know in
the last decade i guess the good news if
you will is that black drug arrests were
down twenty percent the other news is
that white drug arrest the bad news you
look up forty percent the war and
crystal meth that we're seeing right now
if you if you look at the footage which
is
typically poor white people being you
know locked up you know engaged by the
police and locked up it's literally a
film negative I mean just like just flip
what we saw with the Warren cracked 20
years ago and poor black people that's
not progress that's not progress for
this country and you know we need
president and the and the Attorney
General to be even more clear than they
have been that this country needs to
move forward with its criminal justice
policies towards place that makes all of
our children safer and not continue with
the path set by people like Richard
Nixon and George Wallace 40 years ago
Barry Goldwater 40 years we're really
we're going by the Barry Goldwater
richard nixon playbook and it's not
serving our country will